this month the city of Paris unveiled
this is very controversial public
urinals they have public urinals and
these new pissoir zazz they're called
they're upsetting some of the locals
because their urinals that are just out
in the open this is a real thing take a
look see that red box right there that's
a public urinal that you can use if
you're in Paris and you see it just walk
up and use it in front of everybody now
I'm told Andy actually has some pretty
strong thoughts about these new public
urinals you want to share those with us
Andy oh I'm happy to Conan hey Paris I
know you're always trying to be
avant-garde but these public urinals are
going too far
I mean you have a beautiful city and
millions of people come from all over
the world to enjoy the Eiffel Tower and
Notre Dame I mean the last thing they
want to see is a red box with some drunk
guy in front of it taking Lu in all
right Andy Andy I'm sorry quick question
are you peeing into the left turn right
now what are you talking about
oh oh no no you probably you probably
heard us okay yeah I didn't have a
chance to get a drink of water before
all right Oh anyway why don't you go
back to what you were saying yeah oh oh
yeah anyway um yeah the new urinals in
Paris I mean it's not just about the
public exposure that I'm concerned it's
the implicit sexism these boxes
represent I mean men can piss all over
town but women have to hold it I mean
come on is that fair sorry Andy once
again is that same sound is back what
are you doing oh I'm sorry you caught me
I was I was just trying to fix this
decorative water feature at the same
time that I was giving my op-ed I mean
it repairing these is the hobby mind are
so peaceful yeah okay are you about done
now Andy are you done oh yeah I'm done
all right
Oh Andy left fondle a sketch
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I told the director to stay on him way
too long he held it pretty well he's
still going
[Applause]
you